let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
it's wednesday afternoon it's three
o'clock central
and you are listening to let's talk the
tony michaels podcast
and the reason why you're listening to
it because i have not been canceled yet
nor have i taken down my own podcast
i thought about taking my blog down this
morning since it seemed
so popular to take down your own blog
of course i don't have a [ __ ] blog so
but
we did we did see someone take their
blog down
this morning and we could have all kinds
of
great stories of why the former guy
took down his blog the twice disgraced
twice
impeached ex loser president
the blogger in chief he's not a blogger
anymore apparently
he gave up on it less than three
scaramucci's
and he gave up on the blog so we're
gonna talk about that today
of course i think i think we should
really review
fouchy's emails from february of 2020
when they knew nothing about this
particular novel coronavirus
i think we should definitely review
those don't you think
and really surmise on what he was saying
in public
that was printed in emails we should
probably do
that too so i think we'll
get into the fouchy emails
and then i really want to uh give you
guys a few
thoughts on uh the uh
the q anon ku nazi rally that happened
over memorial day weekend
um and bum [ __ ] wherever
mike flynn sydney powell
a whole host of these morons
and i really want to uh maybe talk a
little bit about q anon today and
my feelings on it no one really knows my
feelings on q and i've never
never made it perfectly clear where i
stand
on maga and q anon it's very unclear at
this point
right no [ __ ]
so we want to talk today about the
the trump blog uh so
we watched after january 6 donald trump
be escorted off social media properties
one by one
twitter facebook youtube and he tried to
get back on these platforms but
in recently the most recent one that
told him to go [ __ ] himself was facebook
with their little uh non-biased
commission
that was supposedly gonna you know make
the decision rather
he could be on facebook or not
and they told him [ __ ] no we'll
re-review it in six months
kick the can down the road which means
in six months they're gonna tell him to
go [ __ ] himself again
and twitter banned him way back when i
mean
almost immediately after january 6 i
believe it was january 8th that my dates
are correct i i did a video on it
i did a video on it it's called the
roofie ban if anyone
wants to go find the video it's called
the roofie
ban they [ __ ] banned him
that's the first line from that video i
i remember the first line
so they they banned him from twitter i
believe on january 8th from
several his videos where he was still
inciting violence
uh for this insurrection you know he
waffled back and forth back and forth
back and forth
so then he so then he gets he gets
kicked out of the white house we
we we [ __ ] fired him he packs his
[ __ ] he [ __ ] leaves he goes down to
mar-a-lago
uh he continues to whine and complain
about how he's been canceled
he's not on social media and the rest of
his
horde of maga idiots complain about how
he's not on social media
so he decides he decides a couple months
ago
that he's gonna start his own social
media experience
i don't know the [ __ ] that means i guess
it's the same thing as him going
to the beauty pageants and walking in
the dressing rooms that sort of social
media experience
i don't know i who can [ __ ] tell
it's a blog it's a [ __ ] blog
and instead of calling it donald j
trump.com
blog they said the desk as if it came
from a desk
and he's not on the [ __ ] you know
trying to type this [ __ ] out and
literally i
i think this is what this is he's got
his iphone open
bear with me here he's got his iphone
open he's sitting on the [ __ ]
because he just got his first diaper
change the other day
so he's sitting on the [ __ ] and he's
got his iphone he's got the notes open
and he's pretending like he's tweeting
right and maybe they've confused him
into this they've convinced him that
no no the notes is the tweet sir that's
the tweets
we'll take that and we'll put it on your
social media experience
on your website on the worldwide
interwebs
so he types his little [ __ ] into his
notes
and they take that they put some shitty
ass graphics around it
post it up on the the desk
the desk of former president donald j
trump you know make it sound important
so after several weeks
of continuing to post his garbage like
he always posted garbage on social media
this is not
this is not a surprise that he would
post this kind of garbage
on the internet when we post his garbage
on he just lies and just [ __ ] just
[ __ ] [ __ ] he continues to post
this stuff
and after weeks and weeks and weeks of
this he can't get any traffic
like literally he can't get any traffic
to this website
which really in the world of internet if
anyone knows anything about
paid traffic god damn he could have paid
money and got hundreds of thousands of
views of clicks to this to this website
for traffic i mean if they really want
to traffic god damn you can just go out
and buy it
they couldn't even figure that out
could he figure that out he couldn't get
more than like 15 or 16 000 views on his
on his blog and apparently that's what
they're reporting today is that
that he's he was embarrassed he was
tired of getting [ __ ] about no one going
to his blog even his [ __ ] fans the
maga the maga hat wears these queuing on
[ __ ] they weren't even going to his
blog
they're like what's a blog he's posting
where
what's this social media site the desk
what is this
i mean it literally got less [ __ ]
traffic than than
mike lindell the my pillow nazis uh
social media site frank or whatever the
[ __ ] that thing's called
which we'll get to the q and on [ __ ]
here in a little bit with the their
little nazi rally they had
but it got less traffic than that
now as i'm sitting here thinking you
know what other reason
what other reason could there be that
donald trump pulled his blog off the
internet
what could it be what could it possibly
be i mean we have several criminal cases
that seem like they're gonna
come to fruition here it's possible
maybe that had something to do with it i
i don't know i mean
how would i know how would i know how
would anyone know
i mean last night on fox news eric trump
was on sean hannity crying and
boo-hooing about how they get subpoena
after subpoena after subpoena
i'll stop committing crimes you dumb
[ __ ] and you won't get subpoenas
so maybe that has something to do with
it maybe all the subpoenas and all the
crime has something to do with it
and speaking of crime speaking of crime
he was really really really posting this
garbage about these [ __ ] audits you
know because
these audits were the last hope for this
q and on garbage where he's gonna be
reinstated and again we're gonna talk
about this here in a little bit about
their little
q and on nazi rally now yeah he's gonna
be
reinstated they're just gonna reinstate
him
when arizona the cyber ninjas this is
this is how we're supposed to this is
we're supposed to take this [ __ ]
seriously we are this is not
[ __ ] made up folks this is not made
up
[Music]
a firm if you want to call it that a
group of people
a company called the cyber ninjas i'm
not [ __ ] you
this is [ __ ] real cyber ninjas
botched an audit down in arizona when i
mean botched i mean they didn't find
what they wanted to find
and it seems as if maybe as if
they were trying to create something
that wasn't there you know like
commit fraud to try to perpetuate the
fraud of the big lie that donald trump
won and joe biden
lost what the [ __ ] and it's possible it
looks like maybe
just maybe there could be some crimes
that were committed and he was
perpetuating that stuff on the blog so
who knows who knows maybe follow the
money on that i don't know
i don't it could be a whole host of
things the most likely is it's a dick
contest this guy wasn't getting traffic
on his blog
and he's mad that they couldn't get he
they couldn't get him traffic on his
blog
and no one's reading it of course no
one's reading it no one gives a
[ __ ] about what he says they don't give
a [ __ ] the tail was always wagging the
dog in the first place
they never lend to what he said he said
what they wanted to hear
that was it the tail was always wagging
the dog
in this situation and it led them down
this path
you know believing this just utter
nonsense
and again we'll get to the q and on
rally
that q anon nazi rally here in a minute
it always leads back to these q anon
maga
and just just these [ __ ] dip shits
this nonsense this is why we're still
hanging on because these people are
still hanging on to this garbage
when it's over it's done we're moving on
to bigger and better things people
but they they keep they keep their [ __ ]
going here
so i did a little video today
of course the tiki talk so i'm going to
show it to you here in a minute but it's
about
uh trump canceling his blog and i
surmise in the video that it's possible
it's possible that he can't compete with
other content on the internet
other manga q and on content on the
internet
and i think that's really what it was i
think really what it was dick contest
he wasn't getting near the views that
even some people on twitter
unknown accounts on twitter we're
getting he couldn't even get the traffic
they were pulling
with it with a simple little hashtag so
he got pissed off and pulled the blog
that's what happened he can't compete
with tucker carlson
sean hannity uh marjorie taylor green
matt gatt sydney powell michael flynn he
can't compete with these people and
michael flynn guy can't
he got cancelled i canceled michael
flynn they
suspended michael flynn from twitter
you're out [ __ ] and we'll talk about
the coup attempt
well what he calls what a coup attempt
before it was a coup attempt but now
it's not a coup attempt well we don't
want a coup attempt
in minimar i think that's what the guy
said minimar
i think that's what he said mini mard
the minimar coup attempt we want one of
those here
can we get one of those here mike lynn
can we order one of those do you want
fries with that
so let's play this video that i did this
tic-tac this [ __ ] rant that i did
today everyone likes the [ __ ] rants
this one especially uh
um i like i like all of them they're fun
they're fun to me i like doing them
but let's play it and then we'll talk a
little bit about it blog or not to blog
that is the question
let's talk so the former guy who got his
ass kicked by joe biden in the last
election turned off his blog this
morning
excuse me his social media experience
good
[ __ ] god canceled him from every
other goddamn platform so he decided to
cancel himself
and why not because with all the other
stupid q anon manga horse [ __ ] running
around the internet
you might as well who would want to
compete with the bowtie buffoon rube
over at fox news
tucker carlson it's the son of a [ __ ]
to go up against things like admitting
that republican men are all white
supremacists dr fauci's emails reveal
what he said in public
and not knowing what the [ __ ] jim crow
is jesus [ __ ] christ imagine packing
this much [ __ ] inside one person's
hollow skull
[ __ ] me okay can we just agree that
these ninka poot nazis like michael
flynn tucker carlson cindy powell
marjorie taylor green matt gatz and
donald trump are a bunch of [ __ ]
idiots
the words of the great george carlin
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks that's a great
george carlin bit that he does about
names if you want to see the full bit
i'm sure you can you know just search it
up
tucker or george carlin tucker todd
names
or maybe just names it'll come up you
can watch the whole bit
but george carlin was way ahead of his
time when he said [ __ ] tucker tucker
sucks
way ahead of his time way ahead of his
time
he was ahead of his time on a lot of
things but
let's go back to this this blog thing
because everything trump touches turns
to liquid [ __ ]
have you noticed that i mean absolutely
everything
i mean this this this [ __ ] failure
didn't even last as long as
infrastructure weak
absolutely everything this guy touches
turns to liquid [ __ ] he bankrupts
casinos
trump university turns out to be a fraud
he can't sell enough [ __ ] stakes to
keep trump's stakes open
he he completely completely [ __ ]
botches
everything he [ __ ] touches all of it
the whole [ __ ] thing it's not
surprising that this guy would try to
open up some sort of social media thing
what what he thought
yeah sure yes yes yes mr president
it's it's it's a social media experience
what's that well it's kind of like a
blog
so he became a blogger and he [ __ ]
that up
in less than a couple months that it's
not surprising that this guy everything
he touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
and some people on here or even are even
surmising here that
maybe uh kevin says maybe the bill can't
do on the go daddy and he couldn't
afford the web space which makes sense
it makes sense kevin and the reason why
it makes sense is because this
this guy is supposed to be some sort of
big billionaire
and he's been running ads on on newsmax
and oam and all kinds of places
apparently
begging people for money like him it's
not like
a super pac asking people to give money
to make america great again or oh
we need to make sure that president
trump is reinstalled or some [ __ ]
it is him looking into a [ __ ] camera
saying please send me your money
anything will help a nickel a dime a 20
bill
please send it to me i'm [ __ ] broke
this is supposed to be a billionaire
you know the guy that stood up said i'm
super rich
i can afford my own campaign i don't
need no money i'm not beholden to no
money
and here he is here he is begging
for [ __ ] chump change it's crazy
all the grips all the grips that he had
while he was present and this
[ __ ] still out of money
is anyone wondering that maybe the
criminal grand jury
at the manhattan d.a in the state of new
york
that has his tax returns is anyone
wondering
maybe maybe just maybe that's why he hit
his tax returns all that time he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
about committing crime this guy thinks
he's above the law he always has
always will he always thinks he's above
the law
god damn he's donald trump why not
his dad bailed him out all those years
the banks bailed him out
the government bail him out with with
bankruptcy
and the republican party continued
continuing continue to bail him out
during his presidency
he's always going to get billed out he's
not worried about crime or corruption
he's worried about people knowing he's
[ __ ] broke
a rich billionaire does not go on tv
and produce a commercial looking into a
camera
begging people to give him money
stop what happens so
maybe kevin's right maybe kevin's right
the bill came due
on the web page and he couldn't afford
the 995 this month
it is the second he couldn't afford the
995 this month to keep that [ __ ]
open
and the lights on not only are they not
looking at his blog not reading his blog
they're not even watching his
commercials and sending him money
anymore
they give a [ __ ] about him about as much
as they get he gave a [ __ ] about them
maga that is the q anon moga types
maybe they moved on and said [ __ ] them
who knows who knows
but i think going back to tucker carlson
in the video and i think that's part of
the problem here is they're all trying
to compete for this little bitty [ __ ]
slice of the pie
that was the big fraud in the first
place the big
fraud the big lie isn't that donald
trump
won or that he had that joe biden lost
or
fake votes or dead votes or audits or
whatever the [ __ ]
the lie the big glide the [ __ ]
that continues to on and on and on is
that trump
has a majority of people in this country
that love him
that's all [ __ ] horseshit all of it
we watched a a special election last
night new mexico
and and in a district that joe biden won
by 23 percent the democrat
won by 30 [ __ ] percent 30.
handily wayborn joe biden won
what does that tell you and we're going
to see more and more primaries
rack up here over the next over the next
18 months before we get to the general
election next year
we're gonna actually get to see the
electorate either say yes or no
to this trumpism [ __ ] we're gonna
get to see in real life how many people
want this garbage still
and i believe we're gonna find out that
everyone's gonna say no enough's enough
they had their [ __ ] chance sit down
and shut the [ __ ] up
it's enough there's enough enough of
this stupid q and on manga garbage
it's enough of it we want to move on we
want to live our lives
make money have picket fences and big
huge gas guzzling cars
and go on vacation okay
that's what we want we want to have our
devices and our tvs and our sports and
all that [ __ ] back
we're tired of listening to your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i think that's what's going to happen
we're going to see that in the
electorate
it's going to prove out everyone's going
to vote boom boom boom
that's what we're going to have we're
not going to have this nonsense where
people are clinging on to this trumpism
like here in missouri there's a senate
seat
roy blunt retired it's open well because
it's an open primary for the republican
the moga side
you got eric greitens who is a
trump humper through and through mike
pence's little pet
here in missouri which isn't surprising
and then you have this mccloskey the
lawyer you remember this guy and his
wife
they're they're they're they're tons of
means out there of these people
they were the ones where there was the
the the black lives matter
went to the mayor's house they walked on
the sidewalk past their house and these
people came out with guns
and we're waving them around and
pointing at people act like someone's
going to kill them or something
you know this white maniac gun fear this
white gun culture [ __ ] all out for
everyone to see
and then they were the ones who were
threatened what the [ __ ] you came out
pointing your guns at every
people walking on the sidewalk you dumb
[ __ ]
that guy that guy is going to probably
is going to be in a primary with eric
greitens
the guy who allegedly duct taped a woman
to
gym equipment while she was naked
that guy who used to be governor who
resigned
over it who may or may not have
allegedly may have stole money from his
veterans
associate or is is his veterans charity
guess we'll probably find that out i
don't know
but i would imagine it's gonna be a hell
of a wrestling match to watch these two
manga idiots
fight it out my hope is that jay nixon
the former democratic governor of
missouri gets in the race because
i think he'll slam dunk either one of
these [ __ ]
easy well you know what that means
people
think about that for a second think
about the implications of a manga
primary between
mccloskey the the st louis gun guy
and eric duct tape a woman to a to
exercise equipment greitens
one of those guys wins jay nixon could
slam dunk one of those son of a [ __ ]
it's over this state voted twice this
conservative state voted twice for jay
nixon
as a democratic governor without
blinking an eye
well do you know what that means if a
democrat is a senator in missouri again
that opens up a whole new goddamn realm
this [ __ ] about joe manchin and kristen
cinema
of arizona well that's
that's done i have to worry about that
i think there's 23 i i need to do the
math i believe there's 23
seats now democrats aren't going to win
them all neither are republicans
i mean it's got to go both ways here and
there probably will be a few surprises
and what i mean by that is is some of
these like the mccloskey the greitens
some of these people are going to get
the nominations for the republican party
that's probably where the surprise is
going to be
is how some of these [ __ ] boneheads
are actually the goddamn candidates for
this party
how in the [ __ ] they're going to manage
to to do that across the country i i
don't know
i mean i want the trumpiest of the
trumpiest of the trophiest as the
candidates for their party
i think that's the best situation that
we could have in this country and the
reason why i think it's the best
situation
is because because people will get to
vote
we're gonna get to see what the country
wants
[Music]
that's how it works in a democratic
republic
as people vote for their representatives
to represent them in the republic
government
and when that happens everyone's going
to see
just like we saw 8 million people didn't
there wasn't an extra 8 million votes
for joe biden
it was an extra 8 million votes against
trump
i don't believe 82 million people voted
for joe biden
i don't i believe i believe that 82
that a majority of 82 million people
voted against trump
now there was a lot of votes for biden
don't get me wrong
joe biden was chosen over bernie sanders
who is the the self-proclaimed
democratic socialist
and they're running around calling joe
biden a socialist when joe biden
beat in the primary democrats
in the democratic primary in these
states
[Music]
the democrats the liberals the
neo-liberals the
democrat moderates they voted
to have joe biden as their nominee
not the self-proclaimed democratic
socialist
now right wrong indifferent however you
feel about that that's what
happened so i
i hope that they try to brand up
they try to brand up joe biden as a
socialist
because the people who voted for him in
the primary no he's not
a quote unquote socialist as they want
to call him as if it's a bad word or
some [ __ ]
as if socialist is a bad word
but let's get back
let's get back to the trump blog
so the trump blog is over it's done
finished
even the guy who can't pay his child
support can put out a message saying
jason miller can say
yes it's done i mean he's got more he
puts more effort into putting a
statement out about trump's blog
failing which everyone knew it would
than he does paying his child support
allegedly
but i digress from that so trump's
blog is done finish out of here
see ya [ __ ] so
let's put that issue down let's move on
to last night
uh we see
some emails you know these people are
obsessed with emails they're i mean
absolutely
they're obsessed with emails it was
hillary's emails
they still talk about hillary's emails
on on fox news
in these places i mean they just can't
let the email lady go
continue continue continue here we are
it's
2021 trump's at mar-a-lago joe biden's
in the white house and they're
still talking about hillary clinton's
emails and then last night they decided
uh the the freedom of information act
the
release of the fouchy emails that were
obtained by the freedom of information
act
fioa they weren't leaked no one leaked
them
you boneheads uh buzzfeed and a few
other news outlets actually requested
them with the freedom of information act
see that when you have a free press in
this country when you have a free press
and they try to hold officials
accountable that's what happens is you
use things like the freedom of
information act to get information to
put out there in a public so the public
realizes what actually happened
now with these fouchy emails
so it apparently the the the the freedom
of information act request was from
sometime the end of january to sometime
in april for these emails for anthony
fauci dr anthony fauci
and uh a lot of the emails that they're
pointing to are the very beginning of
february
and the reason why the maga cue and
honor the anti-masters the anti-vaxxers
are pointing to these emails in february
is because anthony fauci was saying the
things
like well we shouldn't have to worry
about mask
and and you shouldn't have to wear matt
they keep framing it up it's all [ __ ]
lies it's all [ __ ]
anthony falci didn't say anything
different those emails and what he said
in alive in person in front of a
microphone
now he was a little more measured about
it when he was in front of a microphone
because he knew everyone could hear him
like he knew not to [ __ ] create
hysteria
because at that point in the beginning
of february we didn't even have a
confirmed case of coronavirus in this
country
this was last year not this year
february
last year 2020.
before we had a confirmed case of
coronavirus in the country
this is when these emails were going out
and specifically the email that they
focused on last night on on twitter and
the internet
was a specific email about
mask because this is this is their goal
they want you to believe that angie
anthony fauci never believed mass work
it was all to manipulate and control you
even though donald trump told you to
wear masks
at one point and he put a mask on and
there's a picture of him they don't like
it
there's a picture of him with a mask on
hell when he came out of the hospital
when he had coronavirus he walked up the
steps with his mask on
remember he stood on the balcony real
[ __ ] stupid it was awkward as hell
and he took his little paper mask off
and stuffed it in his pocket
yeah he was wearing masks
so what's that about and he's got the
vaccine he must be
he must be one of the he must be one of
the cabal
that's what it is he's one of the cabal
that's gotta be he's gotta be a secret
democrat part of the cabal maybe i don't
know
but they're pointing to the anthony
fauci i believe it's from february 3rd
there's one from february 3rd there's
one from february 5th i believe
i've read both of them that they post on
the internet
uh through the again through the freedom
of information act
there's there's hundreds of emails but
these are the ones that the mangas are
focused on because this these are the
ones where anthony fauci's
says the thing that they think they want
him to say that proves that he's
responsible for the whole thing
in this email and alls it all he's
saying is
the the paper number one he's comparing
uh coronavirus to sars because that's
the only comparison
on at on february that they had that was
the only comparison
that they had was the sars so they they
they trudged that out right
and and and maybe we can talk about that
but but but
he says something about not having masks
in a drugstore
like the paper mask that you would go to
a pharmacies he's talking about surgical
mask
is what it seems like he's talking about
and and what he's what i read from the
emails he's surmising that hey
the paper mask it's probably going to be
an n95 mass that's going to help you
protect you really from this virus
that's what he's saying he's telling
someone look if you're going to wear a
mask wear an n95 mask that's going to
protect you
and that's what they kept saying alter
march april may june
um real really i mean if you didn't have
an n95 mask they were telling you to
wear a mask and keep your distance
they were saying this in public so
there's nothing new in these emails
they're just pulling out what they want
just like any other [ __ ] that they do
here
they take a piece of information they
pull out the information that they want
they say look anthony fauci says not to
wear a mask that's not what he said in
email but
you know so basically
they think these emails are i gotcha and
and
the other thing is uh uh they're talking
about this wuhan lab
and emails from the wuhan lab and
somehow he knew
he didn't know oh my god he admitted in
the email that it could be engineered
they said that before they said that in
february that they were trying to figure
out
where this virus came from so they can
figure out what it was
people they said that you [ __ ]
boneheads
were you people not [ __ ] alive last
year in february 2020
or did you just have your head so far up
trump's ass
that you couldn't hear anything else
that was going on
and most people most people regardless
if you are an anti-vaxxer anti-master uh
you think the coronavirus is [ __ ] or
you think it's real and it's a deadly
pathogen
regardless a lot of people weren't
paying attention till the end of
february
when you remember that that nursing home
in seattle
outside seattle washington started to
eat cases and man people were dying in
that nursing home people like whoa
what the hell is going on and then they
shut seattle down
that was the first time i was like wait
a second this coronavirus thing sounds
like
it could be serious like it's a virus
but they're shutting seattle down
and then the entire country lost its
mind
lost its [ __ ] mind when they canceled
sports that's
that's when the entire country went oh
there's something to this when when the
sports league
started canceling their events that's
when everyone's like okay
something's going on here when they
canceled march madness that was it they
were like what well look but
nba is not the we're not playing oh [ __ ]
and then by the time we got to the end
of march that's when all the lockdowns
right at the end of march beginning in
april that's when it started to happen
because san francisco was one of the
first
other than new york but san francisco
was one of the first cities to go
complete lockdown they're like nope
we're locking it up before it even gets
here we're locking that son of a [ __ ]
up
and that's when people realize that oh
my god we're gonna go into lockdowns
that's when it's gonna happen it started
that reality started to set in
but we're talking that was the end of
march beginning of april
these emails that they're pointing out
these emails that they're pointing out
were eight weeks before that
eight weeks it was before the virus even
we had a confirmed case of the virus in
the country which there may have been a
case in the country we just didn't have
a confirmed case
and they were still trying to figure out
what the hell it was where it came from
they didn't know what it really looked
like at that point under a microscope
and you can't yeah for all you q a mega
[ __ ] out there you can't see it
like you know in the air it's it's kind
of invisible
you know like when you cough and stuff
and it comes but if you wear this little
if you wear like a mask over your face
it keeps you from
from coming out oh
[ __ ] just just a buffoonery just a
buffoonery
of the pure physics of how a sneeze
works that these people don't get
is is just it's just laughable
i just i can't even i can't even
describe
how ridiculous this is so
you know fouchy emails that's gonna be a
another another
[ __ ] turd it's gonna go over this
this fouchy email and i've said this in
a few of my videos
this fouchy email thing is gonna go over
like a wet fart in a white thong
is what it's gonna go over like that's
how good it's gonna be for them
and i would imagine the next couple
weeks rand paul is gonna have them all
sitting on his desk questioning anthony
fauci
he's gonna be telling anthony fauci well
you said this you said this you said
this and anthony fauci's gonna [ __ ]
just
ring him up and then i'm gonna have to
play
my rand paul genie video you all know
the one
genie make me rand paul's neighbor
that's the one and i'll get to play my
video and i'll enjoy it because rand
paul is a [ __ ]
because he thinks anthony fauci is
saying two sentences in an email on
february 3rd
about a virus that not a lot of people
knew about then
is evidence that anthony fauci somehow
took over the world
and released a virus in wuhan china and
now there's microchips in your arm or
some dumb [ __ ]
so there you go anthony fouchy emails
good luck maga good [ __ ] luck
speaking of manga and cueing on and all
this horse [ __ ] and all the horse [ __ ]
they believe
this does not just go along with this
coronavirus this mask vaccine all this
stuff this
this boneheadedness does not just end
with that
uh the thing the thing that we're seeing
is these people now believe that uh what
cindy powell said it
we'll go we'll go to the q anon nazi
rally that they had
where sidney powell mike flynn uh he was
encouraged
to yeah we should have a coup we should
do that that's a thing we should do
so cindy powell is up on stage basically
saying
here's what's gonna happen by august
august we're gonna have donald trump
reinstalled
with the courts even though the courts
aren't seeing any of these cases
none of them the audits are getting
struck down these states are telling you
to go [ __ ] yourself with the audits
it appears it appears that there might
be criminal indictments in states like
georgia
where trump and his allies were
committing uh
voter fraud they were trying to rig up
the election it's possible that we might
see
some criminal action with these cyber
ninjas out in arizona
with how they handle ballots it's
possible there was criminal acts who
knows
who knows they were trying to delete
records and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] even the republicans in
arizona saying stay away from this thing
stay away it's bad it's real bad they
don't know what they're doing
they [ __ ] this up even
the republicans in arizona
so city powell gets on stage she's
sitting there and all the confidence in
the world just lying her ass off
something about oh well there's been
cases in this country
where they they reinstalled someone in
an election what a mayor
[ __ ] city councilman what are you
talking about a school board member
but never the president united states
she said that's never happened there's a
first time for everything though well
number one there is a constitution
and it lays out who the president is how
they become the president
and then who's the president if they're
not the president anymore
you [ __ ] idiot like the constitution
spells it out
right there you can read the son of a
[ __ ] it's not very difficult go on the
internet google the [ __ ]
you can even google the succession in
the 25th amendment
of who comes next because the only way
that joe biden leaves office is three
ways
three ways people that's it either he
passes away
he resigns or he's impeached and removed
that's it
those are the three ways and then if he
is he does leave office for whatever
reason
before his term is up that the
constitution dictates
the constitution says who the hell steps
in they don't reinstall anybody
the constitution actually installs
somebody
that's how it works that's how
it works that's the trouble we had for
four years with donald trump being
president
is once he was president you can't get
rid of him unless you impeach him and
remove him
but the republicans didn't have the
balls to do that which
they're probably regretting by now
but then she says so she she is so un
uncoupled
from reality about how oh they're gonna
by august they're gonna the courts are
gonna reinstall him
and then she couples it she couples it
because they said
she says they're gonna set a new
inauguration date
which my guess is i've i've said this
before
and maybe i was correct i've said it in
videos before the one video is called
limp dictator i should have queued it up
today maybe we could have played it
it's called limp dictator
and i surmised on there that possibly
they would move the goal post to
september 89th
so maybe by august when they go to
reinstall him because she said
cindy pal said she said that we would
that we would get a new date we would
get a new inauguration
date maybe it's september 89th maybe i
was correct
maybe i'm spot on september 89th donald
trump is gonna be
re-inaugurated and reinstalled as the
president of the united states
the ump teeth or whatever number they
want the 19th i think the 19th was
march 4th that's what the video that's
when the video is from is from march 4th
the limp dictator video it's from march
4th because remember march 4th was the
actual inauguration
so the military was gonna take and biden
and then
and then trump was gonna he was gonna
sprinkle cheeto dust and somehow that
was gonna make
you know someone grow wings and then i
don't i don't [ __ ] know
who knows with these [ __ ] people
so sidney powell says on stage at this q
and on
nazi rally that donald trump is going to
be reinstalled at a certain date they're
going to set an inauguration date which
is not what happens in the constitution
at all
that is [ __ ] bogus that is so far
from reality that's not even tethered to
anything that looks like reality
and then what she does then what she
does is she
says she says but what will happen is he
won't get a full
term because the constitution sets the
inauguration date
so he'll just have to deal with the
remainder of joe biden's term
so what she does and this is how they do
this stuff folks
is how they do it they give you this
garbage they feed you this garbage
of of lies and [ __ ]
untethered from reality no sense of the
truth
and what they do is they wrap it around
one little one little nugget
which it's not really that not the truth
the truth is that the constitution does
set the inauguration date that's the
only nugget of truth that she had
in the entire diatribe that she sat
there and yapped her trap with
that the constitution sets the
inauguration day that's it
everything else was [ __ ] it was all
untethered from reality but by her
taking all that [ __ ] and drawing it
back to this one little nugget of
reality they go
well it must be true because
constitution she said the word
did you hear did you hear jim she said
the word constitution
it must be true
and then later on in the night the day
or whatever whatever the hell it was
in this little hotel room with these
tens of people cheering on
these traitors these nazi traitors
he's queuing on us we have mike flynn
get up on stage and he's doing a q a
because that's a good idea for mike
flynn to do a q a
fantastic idea let's hear what he has to
say and how he's going to answer
questions that's a good idea actually
i'm serious
we should continue to have mike flynn
have q and a's
probably like in front of prosecutors in
front of courtrooms
juries but you know i digress from that
so mike flynn is taking a q a and a
crazy trump supporter trump humper
stands up and he's talking about miami
myanmar and he calls it mini minimar
like mini bar like at a hotel minibar he
says minimar
and he says hey there's a military coup
and many more why can't we have one
here and mike flynn says
there's no reason not to of course we
can
we should have one here in other words
what mike flynn
is saying is he which he is a retired
three-star general
remember this this guy receives a
retirement check
from us the american people through his
service that he gave to his country
he gets a retirement from that health
care benefits pay
all kinds of [ __ ] this guy took an oath
and he has to continue that oath
regardless
because he took it because he gets a
[ __ ] pension
he gets money so
this guy a three-star retired general
who was fired by obama
who was rehired by trump after he
played ftse with vladimir putin in
russia
to be ahead of his national security
apparatus
then was shamed because he's a [ __ ]
liar
he lied to the feds pled guilty and then
donald trump had to pardon him from all
that
he is sitting on stage decides it's a
good idea this is a fantastic idea i
really should i really should not only
not only play footsie with a coup
i should say that's a good idea and we
should do that
that does not break my oath whatsoever
i'm sure
well see the problem is with these
boneheads is they don't realize that
there's cameras and recorders
everywhere anymore i mean [ __ ]
everywhere
you can't even take a [ __ ] without
someone maybe possibly recording the
sound
these days at least you should expect
that
especially if you're in a public
bathroom because
you know someone someone's got their
cell phone in the stall next door
and if there's weird sounds they may
just you know do a remix
but mike flynn has got to know he's
being recorded and of course
almost immediately it goes all over the
internet this guy is standing on stage
not not only saying it is possible that
there could be a coup but we should do
that
we should do that that's a thing that
should happen the military
should take over and create a coup which
there's a lot of problems with that and
we'll break that down here in a second
but social media went crazy
and apparently mike flynn left because
what happened when social media went
crazy and you realize oh my god
holy [ __ ] they heard me say that i
wanted a coup oh
[ __ ] he calls back to someone at the
event
they go out on stage and they're trying
to get people in the audience
they're trying to get people in the
audience to tweet out he didn't say that
you know they're always whitewashing
revising what actually happens
they always it's it's the trump way they
gotta re-engineer
everything they always [ __ ] have to
re-engineer
[ __ ] everything
everything has to do we did something
now we have to undo it
from the thing that we did so they're
out on stage telling the supporters hey
tweet out that he didn't say that
because they're killing him
now there's several problems with what
he says in the q anon universe that i
see from what i can tell that they
believe or they don't believe or who
knows
some of these q armors believe that joe
biden is not actually the president that
he's pretending to be president donald
trump's actually the president
and he has control he has control
over the government through the military
or some dumb [ __ ]
well if that's the case people are
bitching about the country you know the
gas prices the lumber prices which is
all has to do with the economy and
inflation and the economy ramping up
because
now we've got rid of coronavirus and the
tariffs there's a lot of different
components to this thing but it's not
exactly any president's fault
inflation so anyways they're complaining
about all this stuff
well if that's the case if donald trump
really is controlled and it's not joe
biden doing this stuff
it's donald trump isn't it
isn't it well no no no
no see you don't see see you don't see
it see you gotta we have to pretend
we have to pretend that joe biden's in
charge he's
actually in charge well then okay so joe
biden is in charge
no no he's not in charge it's on a
hollywood set it's all fake he actually
isn't in the white house
so where's donald trump well he's in the
white house but he's in mar-a-lago and
you know who [ __ ] knows what they
believe anymore
they don't even know what the [ __ ] they
believe anymore
they have no [ __ ] idea
so mike flynn's idea is that the
military is gonna create a coup
which even back in january december and
january the joint chief
of the military was saying we take a
note to the constitution
a document not a person they were
broadcasting it hey
people in the military don't believe
what you're hearing about a military
coup it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and here we are still talking about this
garbage
as if he's gonna get reinstalled the
military is gonna do it what the [ __ ]
are you people yammering about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
on and on and on with this garbage
so mike flynn because he's trying to
incite violence and he's trying to
incite a coup
it would appear twitter
tells him to go [ __ ] himself and they
ban him too
so i don't know how many more of these
idiots
uh still there are to ban from twitter
uh these
these traders and these treasonous
[ __ ] but it appears it appears
that twitter is willing to do more about
these people wanting to commit a coup
like a january 6 style insurrection
than what the republicans in congress
are wanting to do jesus christ before
the weekend
the senate voted down they couldn't get
they couldn't get enough senators to
even
agree that the january 6 was treasonous
it was an insurrection and we need to at
least
investigate it which i think is a good
thing folks i think it's good that the
january 6 commission was torn down
it shows who's who and who's what it
showed their vote it showed what they
wanted
now we get to get a select committee and
the republicans aren't going to have any
power over the select committee and we
can actually get to the bottom of what
happened
because also over the weekend we had a
superseding indictment of a bunch of
oath keepers
four were added to a conspiracy and
that's what's gonna happen
they're gonna continue to do these
superseding indictments and and the word
conspiracy is gonna come up
continue continue continuing continue
the word conspiracy
because they conspired with each other
and what's funny is
is in that document in that indictment
there's four new names added
uh there's there was one of them that
had six counts six charges
one through six and there was two others
that had one through four i believe
um so they had four charges against them
and then there was someone at the very
top that was redacted
they redacted a name off the indictment
now if you know anything about federal
indictments that that
happens every so every so often but that
is not a common thing that they actually
redact
someone's name off an indictment they
would just not include you in the
indictment
they would supersede you into another
indictment they can they can get the
grand jury to supersede indictments all
day long
as much as they want they can change the
indictment change their charges add
people take people away
they don't give a [ __ ] it's the feds
they got all the money all the time in
the world they don't care
and when when joe schmo leaves there's
another jack shmoe that's going to come
in and take his place
they don't care
but the redacted makes you think that
either a
it's someone who's flipping or b it's
someone of importance
that they don't want their name out
there maybe they want to terrify the
[ __ ] out of that person
because if you believe if you see that
those three names in that fourth person
it probably has something to do with
those other three people conspiring
now i'm surprised these news agencies
and maybe they have they just haven't
released it because i would imagine
i would surmise that if it's someone of
importance
if it's really someone of importance
it's possibly possibly a member of the
united states senate or possibly a
member of the united states congress
the house of representatives now there's
there's a whole list of [ __ ] names
there that
pop up in your brain and i ain't got
time right now to even go through the
whole [ __ ]
list so
we have mike flynn calling for january 6
style insurrection
sydney powell wanting wanting to to
reinstall donald trump donald trump
pulls his blog down today
there's criminal trials in the manhattan
da's office in the state of new york
also the attorney general of new york is
as criminal charges it looks like in
georgia there's criminal charges
being investigated for uh for
the phone call that donald trump
possibly made and maybe the pressure
they were putting on the election
officials there for
uh to commit voter fraud it's possible
that these arizona audits
these cyber ninjas who knows it seems
like they're deleting information
that seems like a crime to me
allegedly
then we have superseding indictments of
conspiracies of oath keepers
with redacted names possibly in a very
important person
a public figure maybe that's why they
redacted the name
i guess arraignments will come
but here we are folks
everyone thinks that trump is a big
threat everyone thinks that trumpism is
a big threat
everyone thinks that this q a is a big
threat and i believe that there could be
violence that ensues
that's what these people want they don't
care about trump
they don't care about they don't care
about
cabal or whatever their garbage that
they're spewing
they're worried about losing their white
privilege
that's what it is it is a cult it is a
white supremacist cult
and they are focused laser focused on
stoking
normal average white people in this
country that have no idea that's why
they're stoking them
that's my that's that's what i think it
is
now i believe that it is
not sustainable and the reason why is
they keep moving the goalposts keep
moving the gopros keep them in the
goalpost
which means that these people are
eventually going to know that these
people are full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they've always been full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean they can keep lying to him and
lying to you and lying to him and the
people that want to believe it will
believe it
but guys that's that folks that's the
[ __ ] biggest scam of it all
is to think that there's massive massive
amounts of people
that believe that trump is some kind of
messiah orange deity and he's gonna save
us all
that's the [ __ ] fraud that's the
fraud
that's the fraud he's the fraud he's the
fraud
he's not the khan he's the mark
he always has been he's the [ __ ] mark
so thank you for joining me today before
i go though if you guys really like this
podcast which some of i think some of
you
i think you do like this podcast i think
you do like
listen me for whatever reason yell and
scream into a microphone
i would like some support from you
number one
watching and listening thank you very
much
it's so appreciated for you to watch
listen
like share whatever it is that you do
out there for the podcast my content
does cost a little money so if you want
you can support you can get a [ __ ]
sticker
they're pretty cool that's my grift
that's my trump grift
is a sticker so if you wanna if you want
a sticker a [ __ ] sticker that'll help
pay for the publishing fees
for the podcast because let me tell you
something
let me tell you something it doesn't
cost a lot of money to have a blog up
it cost a little more to have a podcast
up
but i don't think i'm going to cancel it
if you guys don't buy any stickers
but you know there is a chance there is
a chance
so
all right guys again come back next week
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern
i know there's gonna be plenty of
[ __ ] that these morons are gonna
talk about they're gonna do
between now and then that's gonna cause
us to have plenty of content
plenty of [ __ ] for me to talk about here
on the podcast
we got one more in the tank this is
episode 21. we've been doing this for 21
[ __ ] weeks
21 [ __ ] weeks and i appreciate
every single week and every single
person that watches and re-watches
and you should you should go back and
re-watch and criticize me tell me how i
suck and tell me how i'm great
i don't know all right guys before i go
there is
one last thing that i'd like i'd like
you to know
and i've been posting it on uh twitter
and i said it my video today so you
heard it before i think it's very
spot on that we need to remember this
this is very important in the words of
george carlin
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks [ __ ] him
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ]